their first taste of freedom in 49 days
that's 1176 hours of lockdown spent
mostly indoors I've been up since 5:30
a.m. waiting for it to be six so I could
go out runners cyclists roller bladers
taking to the footpaths across Spain
which for weeks had been off-limits
except for those out to buy food and
medicine I was rollerblading with open
arms through the streets because there
weren't any cars it was a feeling of
freedom going for a walk and playing
sport had been banned to stop the corona
virus spreading in Spain which is one of
the worst affected countries in Europe
they've been more than 25,000 deaths and
216 thousand cases but authorities say
the outbreak here is finally past its
peak today and I'm thinking I'm like I
feel like you know a story cat moment
you know like it with everybody out like
this so I'm very happy about this and I
think that people are quite respecting
the rule so I think it's a very happy
moment there last weekend children under
14 were allowed out for an hour a day of
supervised Dec tivity now adults and
senior citizens can also go out at
separate times in a bid to reduce
overcrowding though it didn't work
everywhere with thousands out along
Barcelona's promenade for me personally
it's incredible that I can finally go
out after so long it just seems a bit
strange to me that there are these time
shifts because in the end there are so
many people out at the same time in the
same place speeches though remain closed
and crowds exercised under the watchful
eyes of police
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez tweeted
that allowing outdoor exercise was a new
step and measures to ease the
confinement but called for people to be
responsible because the virus is still
here the World Health Organization says
countries should lift their lockdowns
gradually and be ready to restore
restrictions if infections rise there
are tough days still ahead for Spain the
lockdown has hammered it's already
faltering economy and unemployment is
expected to soar on this Saturday though
people enjoyed the simple pleasures of
being outdoors on a sunny spring day
Alexei O'Brien al Jazeera let's go live
to Marta Herrera who's standing by for
us in Madrid and Marta what all this has
been going on the Prime Minister has
been speaking what's he had to say Prime
Minister Sanchez was very pleased that
he had the chance to give us a small
relief to all the Spaniards allowing
them to go out for one hour walk or for
one hour of exercise all ages were out
today in the streets and in second place
he announces 16 billion euros fund for
recovery for all the regions he also
said that from Monday Faceman face mass
will be mandatory the use of a face
masks will be mandatory in the park in
public transport now we are in phase
zero with we are did starting this
de-escalation plan he announced last
week we are preparing to go to phase one
because towards the new normal alright
and so what follows on after that said
after phase one there's this kind of
modulated de-escalation isn't there
well NextEra is facing a phase-one
it would start in in May the 11th where
small businesses will reopen to the
limit of 30% of their capacity and bars
and restaurants with terrorists will be
able to open to 30% over of the capacity
to we will face them 15 days later if
everything is okay monitoring the the
number of infections on the state of a
health where health care system 15 days
later later we will go to Phase two
where bars restaurants theaters will be
open at a 50% of the capacity and 15
days later we will go to Phase three
were all baked malls meal big big malls
could open at a 50% of the capacity all
this has to be done under the umbrella
of the state of emergency lockdown this
a state of emergency had emergency has
been extended from 15 days to 15 days
through the Spanish Congress with the
voting of all the political parties but
what's the challenge that Pedro Sanchez
is facing next week he will present the
next lockdown stage extension but he's
facing plenty of problems as many
critics as he has prompted huge
criticism amongst other political
parties saying they won't support him
anymore with any other lockdown
extension because they're not happy of
how he's managing this crisis that's
moto Herrera as Spain begins the easing
restrictions in phases thanks very much
mother